[Music]
this is a United States Drug Enforcement
Agency we are ordering you to land
hi boys little Andes my name is Barry
seal that's for the damage for your
sister
hey little darling and you're back some
of this [ __ ] really happened you never
saw me out for your class in the Civil
Air Patrol pilot like you shouldn't be
flying buses welcome to Miami
welcome to Bakersfield haven't you ever
wanted something more Barry you should
be serving your country Lucy hey Shh
we need you to deliver stuff for us oh
this is legal if you're doing it for the
good guys
very seals are goddamn genius you are an
airline pilot berry that's how you
support this family this is gonna be
good for us this is how illegal you
trust me oh we're expanding operations
berry
[Music]
Roscoe dug this up in the backyard there
Bill's blown around everywhere I'll rake
it up in the morning guns drugs money
laundering y'all know it caddies have
more trunk space than any other car
I'll get each and every one of you to
caddy your troubles gentlemen walk out
of here too I read a damn thing any
wonder you can do about it he's free to
go well wait a minute boys should have
taken a cash
I was working for the CIA the DEA and
Pablo Escobar Mookie knee and toes kilos
that's 1,500 kilos are in one go get it
done
[Music]
[Music]
you